الى تونس وهناك اعتقلت فرقه مكافحه
الارهاب الزميل سمير ساسي الصحفي بمكتب
قناه الجزيره في تونس واقتادته الى جهه
مجهوله وقد دهمت الفرقه منزل الزميل ساسي
وفتشته وصدرت هواتفه وحاسوب الشخصي قبل
اعتقاله
معنا من تونس مدير مكتب الجزيره لطفي حجي
لطفي هل هناك اي بيان صدر من قبل قوات
مكافحه الارهاب بخصوص الزميل
ساسي نعم محمود الى حد هذه اللحظه اللي
نتحدث فيها اليكم ليس هناك اي بيان صدر من
الجهات الرسميه كنت منذ لحظات في تواصل
مع المحامي الى حد الان لم يعرف مكان
الزميل سمير ساسي المحامون تنقلوا في اكثر
من من مكان للاعتقال واكثر من محكمه في في
تونس سواء
محكمه الابتدائيه بتونس العاصمه او محكمه
محافظه ارانه او القطب القضائي اي المجمع
القضائي لمكافح الارهاب لكن كلهم اعلمهم
ان سمير ساسي غير موجود عندهم والى حد
الان لا يزالوا البحث جاريا عن الزميل
سبير ساسي يعني لا يعرف مكانه الى حد الان
كما ان السبب ودوافع الاعتقال غير معروفه
الى الى حد الان باقي انه طريقه الاعتقال
اثارت امتعاض نقابه الصحفيين
والصحفيين لانها كانت بطريقه
المداهمه وتم تفتيش البيت وحجز كتب وحجز
هواتف حتى هواتف ابنائه تم حجزها وحجز
الحاسوب اي الكمبيوتر الخاص به
وتقول النقابه انه كان من المفروض وهو
صحفي معروف وله مكان يعني عنوان محدد
ومنزل كان من المفروض ان تكون هناك دعوه
لاستدعاء الى القدوم الى احدى الفرق
الامنيه ولا تكون بهذه الطريقه التي
يسميها الصحفيون بالطريقه الاستعراضيه
التي من شانها التاثير النفسي على عائلته
و وعليه وليس هناك داعي لمثل هذه الاساليب
في اعتقال الصحفيين هذه عمليه متكرره
مؤخرا ضد الصحفيين لطفي ام هذا حدث يبدو
فريدا من
نوعه هو امس كان هناك اجتماع دعت اليه
النقابه امس بعد الظهر يعني قبل اعتقد
الزمير سمير ساسي كان هناك اجتماع دعت
اليه النقابه للنظر في مساله اعتقال
الصحفيين لان هناك ثلاث صحفيين الان
معتقلون وا اخرهم
كان زياد الهاني المعلق باحدى الاذاعات
الخاصه قال كلمه في حق وزاره التجاره ف
فما تم اعتقاله في اليومي نفسه وهناك
صحفيان اخران واحد محكوم في قضيه مكافحه
الارهاب بخمس سنوا سجن والزميله ايضا فيما
يعرف بقضيه انست لينجو وهي قضيه صناعه
المحتوى اليوم هناك اعتقال الصحفيين
والمطلب الرئيسي بالنسبه لنقابه الصحفيين
وبالنسبه الى الصحفيين هو الاعتقال وعدم
اللجوء الى القانون مكافحه الارهاب او
قانون الجنائي في ملاحقه الصحفيين لان
هناك مراسيم اللي هي المرسوم 115 والمرسوم
116 التي من المفروض ان يلاحق بمقتضاها ال
الصحفيون الان هناك مرسوم جديد 54 تطالب
النقابه ويطالب القوى الحقوقيه بازالته
لانه اعتبروه بمثابه السيف المسلط على
حريه التعبير يعني يمكن في اي جمله في اي
مقال في اي تعبير ينطق به سواء صحفي او
غيره يمكن ان يتم اعتقاله بصفه سريعه وفق
هذا المرسوم لطفي هل هناك اي تغطيه مؤخرا
مثلا اثارت غضب الحكومه التونسيه او اثارت
غضب جهات ما داخل تونس استدعت مثل هذه
الاعتقالات هو في الحقيقه محمود يعني مثل
ما ذكرت لك لا يعرف ال السبب يعني الان
ال الجزيره مثلا في مكتب تونس اي والجزيره
بصفه عامه لها تغطيه مفتوحه قرابه ثلاث
اشهر على احداث غزه يعني التغطيات من تونس
كانت قليله وتكاد تكان تكاد تكون منعدمه
شان وشان المكاتب الاخرى باعتبار تفرغ
القناه لاحداث والحرب على غزه لكن ليس
هناك تغطيه يمكنكن ان تعاب عليها الجزيره
او تلاحق من اجلها الجزيره لذلك نحن في
انتظار ما سيكشف للمحامين لمعرفه الدوافع
والاسباب التي تم اعتقال الزميل سمير ساسي
بموجبها شكرا جزيلا لك لطفي حجي مدير مكتب
الجزيره